ce film qui traite pas directement de la
sphère elle mais qui s'en inspire
largement alors le pitch c'est isabelle
huppert qui juge d'instruction et qui
est chargée d'enquêter sur une affaire
de détournements de fonds mettant en
cause le président d'un important groupe
industriel
elle va découvrir l'ivresse du pouvoir
et la tristesse de sa vie privée voilà
évidemment on pense à eva joly à
l'arrivage joly a dit en sortant du film
qu'elle avait un sentiment de nausée des
taux courant de ça dans quel sens sinon
je t'ai pas en quoi on est dans quel
sens ni gameiro rien à voir avec le crir
ça fait deux trois jours qu'elle n'était
pas bien qu'elle avait la nausée revivre
des moments difficiles où est-ce qu'elle
avait la nausée de se voir caricaturé
comme ça alors quelle culture et elle
pense qu'elle a fait un travail vraiment
efficace qu'elle a envoyé plein de gens
au tribunal qu'elle s'est donné du mal
ekland a l'impression que ça se passe un
peu comme ça par dessus la jambe est pas
contente eva joly non je sais même
cherche partout notamment annoncé
cherche partout peut-être qu'elle
s'attendait à un film façon costa gavras
ou michael moore si c'est vrai que ça à
en avoir c'est pas assez pas un film d'
enquête quoi est-ce que l'exactitude
même du traitement de la sphère est
important mais on s'en fout en fait moi
je trouve que dans ce film on n'apprend
rien sur la frère elle s'est même encore
un peu plus compliqué quand on sort que
quand on rentre en revanche c'est un
merveilleux festival d'acteurs quoi mia
huppert évidemment dont on suit sur le
visage et et à travers ses gestes la
prise de conscience progressive de son
pouvoir jusqu'à ce qu'elle fasse la
couverture de paris match on voit bien
que c'est la petite juge qui d'un seul
coup comment ça un plus sentir qu'on
dira elle dit à un moment le juge
d'instruction est la personne la plus
importante en france il ya bruel en
grand manipulateur qui balancent les
dirigeants du groupe avant de partir
avec 34 millions d'euros sans avoir
commis la moindre exactions en plus il
est passé pour un con à peu près partout
tout le temps de cette affaire
il a manipulé tout le monde ici bien est
vrai très bien les garder mais dans un
grand coup de joueurs de poker las un
grand joueur c'est là là c'est bien
après lui c'est vraiment un grand joueur
c'est un grand joueur on est des
petits-enfants à côté un mec sans
vergogne sans fidélité très imbu de
lui-même très suffisante
comprenez quand même le risque dans ce
film patrick dans un personnage assez
antipathique quand même j'adore ouais
ouais je m'étais amusé est déjà à faire
un type pas très pas très fréquentable
dans lobo le film de miguel courtois oui
c'est vrai je faisais un des membres
actifs de t a alors l'île lebel huppert
ya patrick bruel et puis à les crapules
et les crapules sont extraordinaires il
yad'abord berléand plus vrai que nature
en le floch prigent mais c'est une
crapule aussi un revenons au film max en
valeur la même barbe la même barre à
cause du psoriasis
voilà c'est ça c'est vous savez à quoi
vous avez du temps mais vous avez du
psoriasis ou le floch prigent son toubib
lui a dit de se laisser pousser la barbe
à cause du psoriasis voilà il se révèle
que nous avons même double ben oui
ah ben tu vois mais moi c'était pour
double menton donc il m'a dit fais toi
pousser la barbe
ouais parce qu'il a dit aussi à l'offre
présent pour son personnage étonnant ce
type qui n'a pas fait l'ena qui n'a rien
à voir avec tous les autres quoi qui est
une espèce d'autodidacte qui est arrivé
au sommet et qui finalement trouve
naturel de se servir de la carte de
crédit de la société
parce qu'après tout ils aideront le
public donc c'est moins bien payés que
dans le privé donc voilà il vient du
privé lui un vrai c'était un grand
patron on doit y arriver
donc à partir du moment où ils entrent
dans le public
les émoluments était beaucoup moins
important elle servait de la carte de
l'entreprise pour arrondir ses fins de
mois pour acheter un appartement à sa
maîtresse wallace h
quelques robes voilà c'est vrai que
c'est bon la comique quelques
manifestations mais enfin il a servi de
fusible pardon aux politiques alors
incroyable assurance au début du film on
voit partir en week-end s'occupant tout
même même du fait que les oreillers
pourrait être allergique et et à la fin
on le voit dans un couloir d'hôpital sur
un fauteuil roulant comme une épave
comme ça c'était assez poignant quand je
lis le premier plan est ce que c'est
resté un plan séquence on le voit tout
en haut d'une tour à la défense
et puis pour l'ascenseur il descend
rez-de-chaussée et en fin de compte il
descend on s'est arrêté c'est bien et à
la fin il est pitoyable
mais c'est ma vie tu le fais bien tu le
fais bien je vais très très humain en
même temps oui voilà c'est ça mais c'est
ça qui est drôle c'est que le personnage
reste profondément humain alors que les
autres sont vraiment franchement
détestable
quand je vais les cités parce qu'ils
sont extraordinaires ces acteurs lors il
ya jean françois balmer ya jacques
boudet il ya philippe duclos ya pierre
vernier et ya roger dumas glam ans qui
joue le rôle de roland dumas ce qui est
quand même très ironique de la part de
chabrol et ils sont extraordinaires
il ya une galerie de portraits
absolument incroyable en chansons soient
mal mais à une une scène l'humour est
d'anthologie ouais bah moi ils sont des
mères mais il est fort c'est chabrol à
il est très fort mais oui il parait
zamili sait parfaitement où il va un
départ et il sait parfaitement où vous
emmener au marathon chambre